The last part of the process is what goes
on in the eyes of the observer.
We refer to this as the response and like
everything else the response is a function
of the wavelength lambda.
In fact the response can be written this way:
it is the integral over wavelengths of the
spectrum of the incoming light of the reflectance
and of the response of the eye to light at
that particular wavelength.
So what we sense in the photoreceptor cells
in the back of our eye is essentially the
result of this particular integral.
Let’s see how that works.
Here is a cut away diagram of the human eye;
at the back of the eye we have the retina
and we are looking at the surface of the retina;
we see a lot of blood vessels and we can see
the optic nerve, which is what connects the
eye to our brain.
If we take a cross section through the retina,
make a slice through there, we look downwards.
We see that there are layers of nerves and
other sorts of cells.
And at the bottom of this stack we have the
light sensitive cells and they look something
like this.
So what is quite surprising is that the light
sensitive cells are not on the surface of
the retina.
They are actually about 500 micrometers below
the surface of the retina.
So the light that falls on the retina has
to fight its way down through blood vessels
and nerve cells and all sorts of things to
get to the light sensitive rod and cone cells.
Let’s look at the rod cells.
They’re these small worm-shaped objects
that we see in the back of the retina.
They contain a chemical called rhodopsin.
And it is a quite important chemical, because
when a photon of light hits it, it changes
its shape, and changes its shape from this,
to that.
And we can see that one arm of the molecule
is in fact being spun around by the impact
of the photon and that is eventually converted
into an electrical signal, which travels along
the optical nerve to the visual cortex of
your brain.
The rod cells are very sensitive to light,
so these are the cells we use in low light
conditions.
This is what we use at night, and the way
they are wired makes them also very sensitive
to motion and it is what we use to determine
that something is moving in the edge of our
field of view.
The rod cells are sensitive to a range of
electromagnetic radiation as shown by this
graph here.
So this is the response curve of the rod cells
and we denote it by the symbol M and it, of
course, is a function of wavelength lambda.
The rod cells are maximally responsive to
light at 498 nanometers.
Basically, mid green color.
The other very important class of cells in
the human eye are the cone cells, and one
of them is indicated here.
They are not that conical.
They are certainly fatter at the bottom then
they are at the top.
Quite a different shape to the rod cells.
The cone cells contain chemicals called photopsins;
they are related to rhodopsin that we have
in the rod cells.
There are different flavours of photopsins
that are sensitive to light at different colors.
The cone cells are what we use for our everyday
daytime activities and in the daytime we use
our cone cells, not the rod cells.
The cone cells contain a chemical called photopsin
and photopsin is related to rhodopsin, but
there are three different flavours of the
photopsins, there are photopsins that are
sensitive to red, to green and to blue light
and so there are three different types of
cones, those that are, that contain these
different types of photopsin, sensitive to
red, green and blue.
So we say that human beings are trichromats.
It means that we have got cells that can sense
three different colors, sensitive to different
bands within the spectrum and that is what
is shown in the graph over here.
Often these bands are referred to by the letters
S, M and L, which stand for short wavelength,
medium wavelength and long wavelength.
We would also refer them as blue, green and
red … in that order.
The response of the short, medium and long
cone cells are shown here.
We can see that there is quite some overlap,
particularly between the medium and long wavelength
cone cells, and also shown here for reference
is the response of the rod cells we looked
at in the previous slide.
Let’s look more closely at the retina and
there are two key landmarks in the retina.
One is what we call the fovea, where we have
an enormous concentration of light sensitive
cells.
The other big landmark which is where the
optic nerve joins the retina, and that area
has almost no light sensitive cells—it is
actually a blind spot in your eye.
So if we project those two points down and
we draw an axis, we can plot the concentration,
the density of cone cells as a function of
angle away from the fovea.
So on one side we have the direction towards
your ear, on the other side we have the direction
towards your nose and we can see there is
an enormous concentration of cones in the
fovea area and a much lower concentration
of cone cells in the rest of your eye in what
we call the peripheral vision area.
If we look now at the distribution of rod
cells we see almost the converse; we see that
there are very many rod cells in the peripheral
parts of your vision, not too many of them
at all in your fovea.
So the fovea, we have a very high concentration
of color sensitive cells, the rest of the
eye there are a large number of cells that
are sensitive to light but don’t distinguish
between different colors.